uh what is chernobyl about chernobyl is
about the
um the nuclear
accident at the chernobyl site and
uh how it very nearly made most of
europe uninhabitable
without the dramatic intervention of our
characters and emily's character
and the heroic sacrifice of uh
several thousand ukrainians who
history haven't that we don't really
know their names but they uh
they sacrificed themselves to prevent
the disaster from getting worse
so in a nutshell what would you say i
think that was very well thank you so
much
i play valeri legarsov and he
is the the leading
nuclear expert who
is assigned to try and figure out how to
um how to prevent this disaster from
spiraling out of control
and i play with boris cherbina who is
who is the minister
in the government and who gets the job
to take care of the accident
and at first i'm very skeptical about
this scientist
guy yeah of course science
i'm like trump and all those politicians
but about
facts but eventually
i see i learned from the disaster and
what's happening there
that there there are certain flaws in
our
our uh soviet political system that has
sort of
contributed to this catastrophe and and
we grow
grow closer to each other and eventually
work together in the film
i was approached they asked me if i
wanted to be in it and they said jared
was in it and
and they wanted emily in it as well
and it was very very good script sneaky
because i think
they sent the script to me and
approached me and they said you were in
it
yeah that's how they do yeah that's how
they do yeah oh if
he's in it i'll be in it yeah exactly uh
the scripts are really good they're
really well written
we only got the foot first forward they
didn't get the fifth one
um and uh it was a page toner
it was really gripping very exciting one
of those things that you think you know
you knew what the story was but you
really didn't and you didn't
understand the personal journeys and the
stories that were involved or
how potentially catastrophically bad it
was
for pretty much for the whole of europe
and i remember um i was in london at the
time when the the famous cloud
starts to drift over so i had sort of
memories of it in that sense so uh
i was curious to know what had actually
happened and i was also interested in
working with johan rank i wanted to work
with him before but it never happened
and
and he's done a fantastic job
i did there was not much to find
in in researching but it's gerbina
and i saw that he looked something
completely different than me
so i decided i wanted to look look like
a casigan or
beckett or something instead so i went
another direction there
the preparation i'm really
mostly interested in finding out what's
good for the script of what's good for
the story
more than than doing uh
trying to imitate the surface of reality
but i don't know how did you prepare i i
started well interesting enough because
your character is
is more documented isn't he well
it's he is although um when you start to
look online and
they did a pretty good job of uh rubbing
him out of the record
so there is there's some photographs
there's there's some footage of him
um i quickly realized that i didn't look
anything like him either and also
the the function that the character
plays in
craig's script was very different to the
one that he actually played so um um
i actually was one of the first times
that i've
done research on something and realized
that a lot of it wasn't useful so
i i stopped and just concentrated on the
script
um and then there was a lot to
concentrate on
uh we were all happy that you
concentrated on the script it was good
it was helpful it was helpful at some
point to concentrate on the script
you know generally that's what you're
going to shoot you don't shoot your
research you shoot the script
that's true yeah i'm glad i said the
most challenging part was getting your
head around the science
yeah um because there's a lot of there's
a lot of words
that are related to science yeah and um
you know one of the reasons why i became
an actor i don't invite you is was i was
really bad at science
it's a very challenging text and a lot
of um
ideas that you have to uh convey
and um and then you do need to figure
out what it is you've also got to
understand what you're talking about
um and that it is a challenge
i i've got to the same point in the um
uh brief history of time about you know
the stephen
hawking thing i get to the same point
every time and then i just hit a brick
wall i can't get past black holes
which is really only like the first
chapter um so
it is if your mind isn't geared towards
that stuff
it it is difficult um but luckily
craig has written it so well that it
is understandable even for actors
actors even actors can understand the
science when we can get actors to
understand it i think anyone can
understand it
no i i don't know i've been asked to
to say how do you do it and and i
still don't know how to do it but but
i've learned to listen
and that is i think really important to
listen to your fellow actors
and to take what you do from them rather
than from something you rehearsed in
front of the mirror at home
because a scene scene
if it's good it happens between people
it's not solos at least i'm not very
fond of that kind of acting
so i think listening could be a good
thing what do you think
well i i mean emily talks about the
advice that you gave her
on on the first uh breaking away yeah
what was that
it was something about whatever you have
planned um whatever you think you're
going to do
let it go or something talking about on
that side
you did well she always repeats it so
she thinks you know
she's with us yeah yeah um i'm happy
about that
yeah i thought it was great advice yeah
you have to let go
you you can't um the hard thing in in
what i think is the hard thing in cinema
a little different from theater because
theater you you are
a living human being in the same room as
the audience but but on film you just a
two-dimensional flat picture which means
that
bringing true life to it is much harder
uh uh the audience can't smell you
uh but it is much harder which means
that that
life you cannot plan life and what
what appears on the screen as life is
usually not the things the clever things
you
you figured out at home and planned it's
the things
that happen in the in the moment anyway
which means which is sort of the idea
um i mean when we work we we we don't do
the scenes exactly the same in two takes
it's it
because different things happen he looks
at me in a different
situation it looks a little different
his line comes out differently and then
my answer comes out differently
and that's the fun of it of this job
is is that things you couldn't plan
grow in front of the camera and becomes
life
yeah you have to see i would have said
my thing is i always want to be prepared
when i show up
but um you have no clue what the other
person is going to do
and um you you can't block that out you
have to
allow what the other person is going to
do to change
everything that you thought you might do
so that
because then it's you're capturing the
interaction between the people i would
say
yeah burma said he was he was always
extremely well prepared so just to be
to feel the absolute safety to be able
to improvise
now i mean he did not let his actors
improvise that much but still
you